[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler free review
of ready or not this movie has been
getting a lot of press recently it's
getting a lot of hype it has a really
good score on Rotten Tomatoes
however this falls under that case where
people forget that Ron Tomatoes is just
giving you a score saying that eight out
of ten critics alike to the movie it
doesn't mean they loved it or think it's
great and everyone was saying it is
great are just following the crowd and
are lying to you trust me this is
totally an overblown movie people saying
it's groundbreaking right you will see
quickly that halfway through this movie
it becomes your pink by-the-numbers
horror thriller and someone running away
from somebody and it just drags on even
at a short runtime it's not as clever as
it thinks it is it's a very simple
script and very weak it's also dark
humor in it it hits sometimes but mostly
not and this suspense doesn't work for
me I didn't feel any tension and that as
a result also I believe of
one-dimensional characters across the
board and that takes away the weight a
lot from it and you just it makes it
also super predictable which also leads
to not having much dispense or them
claiming this is a mystery really isn't
you could call everything from the first
scene when you introduce these
characters and what they're gonna do and
then it makes it boring and I just feel
like it was totally a letdown in the
sense of Wow okay you have a great lead
great cinematography it's lit
beautifully and the production design is
amazing the house Suren is so cool and
it starts with this coolest concept
about the game
what I mean by that is you'll see from
the beginning that they have to play a
game and it's as you can see from the
trailer similar weavings character has
to survive basically and there's this
crazy family however that is like the
amount of creativity you're gonna get
and really nothing else it's again just
has this one concept people fell in love
with
then the rest doesn't like grow off of
that it kind of just sinks off of it
which is really disappointing and you're
just gonna see a lot of things you've
seen before and if you have high
standards like me you're gonna be pissed
off because you see so much potential
here and it's ultimately disappointing
and if you think this is a movie or
you're waiting for a really good twist
that makes it some of the shortcomings
worth it that's not here unfortunately
I'd like some of the ending scene but
again it's alright it's just overblown
and yeah cool Adam Brody he's fine he's
not bad but again it's kind of like I
was saying about Bill Hader and it it's
overblown like people go wow this is
incredible I think people just get
excited from a familiar face and I'm
doing a job well done which they did but
it doesn't mean they're doing better
than anybody else it was good so again
if the only thing I would say is if you
want to see a breakout performance I
would be Samira weaving here might get
excited about her as an actress
otherwise pass it skip it wait for it on
HBO I'm giving this one a six point one
trust me on this if you have again high
standards and want something that makes
you feel like you've not seen it before
and there was a lot of effort put into
the story it's not this movie but let me
know if you plan to see it I'd love to
hear your thoughts on that
and yes once you see it check out my
spoiler review as well please follow me
at sea Varley won on Twitter and screen
for more of me and I'll see you next
time